حتى هذه اللحظه ما سجل هو وسقوط 12 مبنى
في بلدات حارم وسلقين والاتارب وايضا بلده
جنديرس هذه المبانية كانت ايله ومهدده
بالسقوط ويبدو انها تاثرت بفعل هذا
الزلزال بالنسبه للمدن التي لم تصبها
اضرار جسيمه سقطت بعض النوافذ وواجهات
المباني وغيرها ما تسبب بجروح لدى سكان
المنطقه الذين كانوا في الشوارع المؤكد
حتى اللحظه هي 55 اصابه فقط ممن القوا
بانفسهم من النوافل ومن شرفات منازلهم
نتيجه الخوف والهلع تحدث عن رقم حقيقه
كبير مقارنه ب130 اصابه في شمال غير سوريا
حتى اللحظه الرقم مرجح طبعا بشكل كبير
للزياده لانها لا تزال هناك توافق كبير
على المستشفيات في المناطق الداخليه من
شمال غرب سوريا لان المستشفيات هناك هناك
نقطه مهمه للمستشفيات التي كانت متواجده
في المناطق التي تبررت بشكل كبير فعلا
زلزال على الحدود السوريه التركيه
يبدو انها سيتم اخلائها خلال الساعات
القليله القادمه لانها كانت اصلا
متضرره متفضعه وكانت تقوم بعمليات الاخلاء
العاجل او الاسعافات الاوليه في خيام وضعت
على ابواب هذه المستشفيات ثم يتم نقل
المصابين الى المستشفيات الداخليه الامنه
نسبيا